[Music]
all right let's go to melody
in knoxville tennessee melody how are
you
i'm doing okay excellent how can i help
all right so um my boyfriend
has asked me to quit my job and move in
with him
um between the two of us we have
five children okay and
this means i will be taking care of his
kids
full-time that concerns me because we
have
very different parenting styles
and i'm wondering what the best way
would be to go about it in such a way
that the tradition the transition is
best
for our kids
man so first don't move in
okay you are not ready for that
just listening to your usage of pronouns
and listening to your usage of
you are speaking about this situation as
far
arms length as you can get it
okay this other person is asking me to
quit
my job and take care of his kids
you're not there yet okay and i don't
mean this is the end of your
relationship i don't mean that this is
what are we doing why are we it just
means right now you're not there yet
okay do you agree with that or no um
i wouldn't say i agree with that i've
been a
stay-at-home mom for quite a while i'm
very comfortable as a stay-at-home mom
and he knows i want to be
one again okay so what is what
okay but you've got a hang up what is it
um well
the only real hang up i have about it
because there's a lot of necessity in
many ways he's helping me out by doing
this because
i'm not in a good living situation and
this
is like very much a lifeline for me
so i'm very happy with that idea and i
was actually very grateful for
the offer okay the only thing is
um when it comes to our relationship
like the only real concern that i have
and i'm an exceedingly pessimistic
person especially when it comes to
relationships
just to let you know excellent i i look
at every dude like yeah
yeah you have a curveball what is it you
know absolutely you're gonna throw
something at me
hey real quick just an aside where'd
that come from
uh that mindset yeah i prefer to be safe
than sorry and well the fact that i'm a
single mom shows that my
other relationship didn't work out too
well you've been sorry before okay
all right so this so you this is a good
thing so what i would tell you is
um i'm not always right
uh-huh but i need you to hear
your language back to you okay okay
somebody you're gonna marry
isn't quote-unquote helping you out
someone you're gonna spend the rest of
your life with invest
in their kids co-raise their kids while
they co-raise your kids
that's how to help each other that's not
doing you a solid
that's not you helping out him with
babysitting and him helping out you
getting you out of a job
and you got a crummy living situation
you are setting yourself up to be
um roommates really good roommates that
hook each other up
hey bro you keep take care of my pets
and i'll give you a cut on rent
sweet good deal that's
not saying hey we are going to integrate
our lives together
and we're going to create a new family
out of what was previously two families
or three families or whatever it was
and there's a whole different ethos of
of going into this
and so it may be that you're trying to
have both where you're trying to be safe
and protect yourself
and get into this family and
take this thing for a spin whatever it
happens to be
i'm telling you you're setting yourself
up for it not to work because you're not
going all in
you're going as a business arrangement
or as a roommate partnership and not
as a potential wife
potential combined blended family does
that make sense
yeah and i guess i can i can see very
much
how you would see it that way um i think
that's probably how i would have thought
if i was
me two years ago okay so i
understand where you're coming from 100
okay
but that is not how he comes across to
me
um he's been good to me in ways that my
husband of 10 years never ever was okay
and has been going out of his way to
make sure
that like the road is as paved for me as
possible
and you know
he's been giving me the language that
expresses commitment
saying you know i'm going to get married
i want to have
a child with you when we're ready i want
to do you know he's not
being that boyfriend who kind of keeps
you at arm's length says but you could
do stuff for me
okay are you keeping him at arm's length
um no i don't think so okay
okay so whenever this show airs i want
you to go back and
listen to just your first statement okay
but we'll let's let's move on i trust
you you love him
you're all in on this deal so how can i
help
so my like i said only real concern with
this
is we both have exceedingly different
parenting styles
what does that mean um he
is um the father of only daughters
i'm the mother of only son okay and
i am exceedingly strict
i have my expectations for my boys my
boys know that they have to
behave this way they have to do these
things everything that you were
describing
earlier about going outside that is me
a hundred percent good for you video
games are for
weekend night only okay but his
daughters will wake up in the morning
grab a soda
and sit down and start playing video
games and he's totally people
and also you know he
he just i think you know because they
have not really had access to their
mother and he feels a lot of guilt for
that
he's been like really lavishing on them
he'll buy them things for no apparent
reason
he doesn't expect much of them like
you know my kids are younger than that
than his but they wake up and they know
they have a chore list they know
that they have to finish all their food
they know they have to wash their plate
they know that
i expect them to read books and you know
just all this stuff
whereas his girl in comparison to my
children are feral
i mean and um so
i kind of wonder okay well if i'm gonna
be with these
girls full time and with my voice am i
supposed to
try to
have them disciplined to the point of
that my boys are work them there
or am i supposed to just step back and
say you know these are his girls they're
gonna be raised that way
but if they are raised differently come
to have resentment when they see
that these girls are spoiled and have no
expectations and they are
free to just do whatever they want and
my sons are being told no you have to do
this you have to
this you can't have that yes but
and if i treat these girls differently
even if they see it as positive like oh
you know she doesn't put these
expectations on us
won't that in their mind make them go
then she doesn't see us as our
her children she doesn't see her herself
as our mother
otherwise she'd be treating us when she
treats her kids
so here's the thing i want to transition
well
yes please you're going to do whatever
you're going to do but for the sake of
those kids
all five of them don't move in yet
okay okay your relationship is not in a
place
like again i want you to go back and
listen to this the judgment you have
over this man that you love and i do
believe that you love him but you don't
like how he parents
you don't think he does it the right way
and you don't think and he probably
thinks you're strict
um you don't like the way that he has
chosen to deal with
the fact that you know his her their
mother isn't
there's a lot here and yes you have
nailed it trying to combine these two
families without some sort of commitment
to
we're gonna we're unifying this family
because when you
when you're combining blended families
like let's say you're both getting
married this weekend and you'd call me
we are all in then yes what y'all are
gonna have to do
is really be intentional about what kind
of parents we're gonna be
and that means we're gonna have to set
some really firm boundaries
and it is gonna be world war three
because kids are gonna
bang their head up against those
boundaries to see if they hold
and they especially kids of um
who have gone through divorce they've
lived in chaotic systems
they've been around heartbroken adults
they've tried to prop them up they think
that
to some level this is their fault and
then somebody comes in and says hey no
more cokes no more video games you go
outside you
then you would have to have a season of
understanding that you're going to be
the
considered the worst person on planet
earth
and you're going to have to have your
boyfriend's husband's
full backing so that when those girls
run to their mom
or run to their school counselor and
they declare war on you because you're
holding them to this standard
and their bodies get off of sugar and
start sleeping and get off of the bleeps
and the screens
it's you're in for a long transition
and vice versa when you're boys who've
been raised
for the last how long have you been
divorced um
about a year okay and how long have you
all been separated
uh about a year i mean it's kind of been
well it
it's complicated my husband decided that
he didn't want to be with me but didn't
want to divorce me so he moved out but
he would come back whenever he wanted
and he um please please please please
please
paying for he was like paying all my
utilities and stuff and i was just kind
of putting up with it
when he started saying he can see other
women too that's when i said you know
what i'm done i don't want to do this
i've been doing
four years i'm done listen your boys
have got to get some stability
and they've got to get some sort of
adult stability in their life
and taking those boys from that chaotic
situation
chaos dad's just gone dad just plops
back in
dad's deciding hey i'm gonna have
girlfriends too that relational chaos
between you and him that manifested
itself into the air of that home
which is i get it man the the it's not
to
beat you up over that there of course
there's going to be relational chaos in
that home
if that's the kind of house your husband
was trying to hold together
or that you were trying to hold together
on behalf of that of your husband acting
like a child
and then to take those boys put them
into a house with girls who were being
raised completely different with a guy
you're
not all in on you've been with less than
a year
man you're i'm just telling you you that
it's it's chaos find a new place to live
continue having conversations with your
current boyfriend about hey
what would this look like down the road
not hey
saying all the right things i don't i
don't care about what people say
i care about people how they are right
you all start having conversations about
hey this is how i feel strongly about
not giving kids cokes at nine in the
morning i feel strongly about kids being
outside and playing together
and using their imaginations and not
being on screens and he may say i
feel really strongly about letting kids
just do whatever they want in the
mornings i feel really strongly about
letting kids play video games they're
growing up in a digital world
and they're gonna have to know how to do
this whatever the thing is y'all are
just really far apart
and i get that it would probably be
better financially you're as you said in
a bad housing situation whatever that
means
i get that it would be easier telling
you
the casualty here will be those kids all
five of them
you all aren't ready for it man you're
not ready for that
if y'all were 19 and 20 and you always
can move in together i would tell you
don't but
it the stakes would be lower it would
just be y'all you got little kids man
they got to heal from this
you take that whatever you will you're
probably gonna do it anyway and
you're grown up you can do whatever you
want to i'm just going to tell you to
hold off man
hold off melody and get some healing
under your belt get some healing in your
in the house give those boys some some
stability all right